right it's the queen's gambit that's
been the theme of levon iranian's games
especially when he's had black the
queen's gambit accepted
black did temporarily win a pawn white
won that pawn back
and now we see a slightly rare move this
last bishop uh last bishop move coming
out i played it myself black here does
have a problem and that tends to be with
space white's central pawns are very far
advanced and therefore white is often
able to launch an attack it's just about
where the way ye
can control his extra space here with
white you need to catch up with peace
development you should bring one of
white's knights out here for example but
uh black does have at least have a
stronghold on the d5 square nice outpost
for the black knight
this opening
tends to have a
slightly better reputation for white but
uh early days
the white knight now developing
and black solidifies the center
the big question in this type of opening
actually which side does black castle
black often actually castles on the
queen side on the left side of the board
because uh i guess if you cut on the
other flank with black you do invite an
attack simon you've talked about the
white
kind of pawn structure especially the
white e5 pawn
when that white e5 pawn exists
black's king doesn't feel safe
on the king side right yeah it doesn't
feel safe on the king side at all i mean
but it's exciting for us
and there we see a night being developed
and
well we expect as david mentioned that
white just continues the development and
we get
the big
well race where both sides attack each
other and i'm noticing something
interesting we were talking about
drinking his tea earlier now last season
in the tour the wonderronian seem to
have success eating his seeds and the
seeds are back he is snacking on
something and i suspect it is the seeds
yeah i think
i was in armenia many many moons ago and
i remember there was a very nice uh
treat where you think it's roasted
pumpkin seeds very very good for the
brain yeah
okay secret to success there yeah i did
not know that maybe i should try some
brain seeds yeah
i do know that magnus is a very
particular or he or maybe used to be
very particular when it came to
nutrition you know he wouldn't be eating
sugar because sugar would give him too
much of a rush and then there would be
the dip and the same goes for caffeine
as well um too many dips and you need
your energy to be stable and sort of
plant the seeds for success
but david you like to be hungry when you
play you said that before
you don't like to snack on something
yeah i don't mind a little bit but i
definitely can't have a full meal
just before a chess game because for the
first hour or two i just feel lethargic
a bit drowsy uh if i've just eaten but
how about during the game especially if
it's a long classical game if you feel a
dip different energy what what will you
eat yeah i like to bring a banana or
chocolate bars maybe but i'm not really
i mean i'm too disorganized basically to
go to the supermarket so often i'm
rushing for a game i'm like oh wait i
need a snack and there's nothing
available
yeah i think bananas maybe a chocolate
bar or two yeah um are good ideas oh
these seeds yeah you need the seeds to
succeed
get a hold of whatever and uh lebron is
eating and just repack it into succeeds
chess players
if you win
we'll do that
yeah and uh well the game is continuing
in the course that david predicted early
on
black is getting ready to castle the
king to the left
and here we have it a very sharp
position
and
well
whilst that lavon aronian is munching on
the seats
well we also love to see your selfies
because it is the final and it's getting
all dramatic and mark keener says
play chess against this guy and i'm
pretty sure this is oh marvin the alien
from i want to say
the space jam
yeah yeah looney tunes that's the one
is it yeah yeah i love that movie yeah
and uh i can't remember whether marvin
is faced or whether marvin is depressed
that's another film isn't it like i
think that's hitchhiker's guide for the
guy yeah
the galaxy marvin is the depressed robot
there yeah 42
my age is the
the meaning of life meaning a life
that's right yeah the depressed robot so
yeah
and
also bassem says that uh they thought
that their turtle would win the prize
yesterday but he didn't so he's going to
replace it with the two little turtles
oh and sends us some more greetings from
tunisia thank you very much for some and
they're so cute aren't they absolutely i
i do like turtles and uh yeah and uh
that well
keep on coming yeah definitely yeah keep
them coming and uh remember you can take
your selfies or you can send us your
thoughts and even enter the crypto cup
challenge by tweeting us using the
hashtag chesschamps and when it comes to
the crypto cup challenge don't be shy no
just test yourself and see what fun you
can have absolutely
and if you have questions as well for
our experts in the studio use twitter
and we can answer any questions you
might have and my question right now
david is what's happening on the board
the king is on that side where we often
see drama yeah
definitely drama in this game ahead
we're not going to see any quiet kind of
strategic battles here we're definitely
going to see one side attacking it's yet
to be seen uh which side that will be
where you will hope it's him because
black's king
i mean there are some defending pieces
around it but it's maybe easier to
attack you can throw pawns towards it
you can throw pieces forward later
it's slightly difficult to attack the
white king black's only way to do that
is to push harry the h pawn down the
board at some point but that does take
several tempi several moves first level
neroni and he's just trying to jump in
with the black knights most likely to
that outpost on the d5 square that we
talked about earlier in front of white's
central pawns
but i mean if we talk about
the position itself but also maybe the
styles of the players who looks more
happy with their position maybe who's
done the better research
levon just like the last game he looks
like he's familiar with the plans he
knows where the pieces belong he knows
what he wants to play were ye
spending quite a lot of time for what is
as far as i know quite a standard
position
he could have predicted this way ye
levon's been playing this opening uh the
queen's campaign accepted
pretty much the whole tournament
so why is he thinking at such an early
stage yeah in a well-known type of uh
kind of setup yeah that's true i mean
this this is a well-known position i
mean i i would have thought on the other
side of that this position suits weighty
uh because uh you mentioned before the
browns have started he wants something
sharp he wants to attack aronia and he
wants to go for his king and when you
have the kings on the opposite side of
the board uh that that is one of the
most interesting cases in chess no
pieces have been exchanged and you can
often just throw your pawns towards your
opponent's king and at some point i
think this game will come really to life
um so i think it's gonna be a very
exciting middle game and uh the last
move
looks pretty logical to me bring the
knight uh maybe into the center next
move and towards black's king um and i'd
probably take white in this position
just because it's easier for white to
play and again that's a real thing you
have to think about when you're picking
your openings is the position easy to
play not always is it a good position
but is it easy to play obviously having
a good position
kind of helps as well you know talking
of ease of play here simon what would
the plans be
uh maybe if white's position is slightly
easier to play
what would be the easy plans the simple
plans you mentioned bringing a knight in
maybe yeah i mean a knight to the center
are then trying to bring it to a square
that's very typical in a sicilian this
square here uh which which you're
demonstrating which attacks the queen
that'd be a lovely square for the night
and i think you know if it can ever land
there black would have to capture it uh
other ideas we've talked about what we
call a porn storm
and uh a porn storm is um you don't
really do this when your king's on the
same side because it's very risky but
here white can start
at some point using his pawns and he can
start pushing them up like the pawn on
the wing all the way up to try and open
up black's king you know you're using
that little warrior he's like a little a
little assassin and he's going all the
way up the board and he's going to try
to you know find a way through
the opponent's defenses his king so and
both of those ideas yeah yeah
you may we may have seen this before
right i have actually never seen this
before but i can tell you one of us in
the panel has actually played a game in
it i know who that is
and uh it's sabino brunello
and uh david howell 2017 the game ended
in a draw so
my question to you david is how
comfortable did you feel in this
particular position with the black
pieces very good question i did not feel
comfortable at all um that was the first
time ever
that game that i'd played this set up
for black in a tournament game and
i'd done a lot of studying beforehand i
prepared for two three hours um i hadn't
predicted this exact variation from
white but i'd looked at the ideas and
suddenly we got to the board and i was
just sitting there thinking oh my
position is so much uglier over the
board than it looks on a computer screen
when the computer says oh it's roughly
level and uh i did draw that game i got
a decent position but
yeah
again uh
not in classical chess i think classical
right so
you must not like that yeah the kind of
positions and uh
that's you often find that don't you
even when you prepare
you kind of it's very easy just to look
at the computer yeah and not to look at
the position because you're following so
much what the computer says but you
actually have to like do i like this
position and uh we've mentioned some of
the plans that white's got and it just
seems like it's a bit easier for white
to play but aronian has picked this line
so he must have some confidence in it
from the black side as as well black is
still relatively solid these pawns
he hasn't touched them so if you touch
one of the pawns simon you mentioned the
word hook a couple of days ago and then
there's a hook something that white can
grab it and grab on and kind of wrench
apart the black structure but these
pawns haven't committed that's good
defensively there are two knights around
the black king so even in that game when
things well when i didn't like my
position when things go went slightly
wrong i did have nights around to jump
into outposts and to hold everything
together uh meanwhile white just pushes
a pawn to defend his knight just uh a
rock solid are we still in uh howell's
game don't think this last move was okay
at least
and uh black meanwhile does have plans
for example black and push this pawn
start chipping away at white's kind of
the spearhead of white's pawn structure
that can also just soften up the black
king and uh you mentioned the little
warrior for white this could be a little
warrior for black if it ever lands
anywhere near the white king then long
term white king does feel
a bit unsafe so yeah a bit of
maneuvering ahead i expect but either
way either both sides are going to
attack in that game at some point white
did try to jump in with a knight it
might be quite similar and then we'll
see that exchange that simon mentioned
yeah so are we in for another
entertaining fighting game yes
absolutely i mean this is not going to
be your boring draw where everything is
symmetrical no no no no
here there is a real fight on the board
and
one thing that's i find
again quite curious is how little time
levon has used on his clock
again yeah
and i have to say i i would
i would say to all our viewers be
cautious about playing your move so
quickly yes it's a sign of confidence
but do remember that there is like years
and years of study behind these these
moves that aronians are is making and uh
if you're just learning the game then uh
be a little bit more careful and uh just
scout the whole board before you play
instantly and the reason i'm saying this
is because often as children we play
incredibly quickly
and
you know everyone is playing a two-hour
game and
as children we're we're in it for five
minutes and then we're out
i think when we're young we don't
realize how much
scope there is we think that we know the
best way we believe in our innate
ability we think okay i'm just gonna go
straight for the king done but uh at
higher levels yeah there's always so
much more detail there's always finesse
there's always little
uh kind of things here and there that we
want to consider that we should spend
time considering
and yeah unfortunately not all of us
have time
like these professional players to
i mean all of the viewers at home they
won't have time to study as much as some
of these guys have done
levon i'm sure he's studied this type of
position at least for dozens and dozens
or maybe even hundreds of hours in his
life wow so that's why he can play so
quickly he's familiar with the ideas the
patterns it's just adapting those
patterns and
into the position into the exact
move orders
yep
and i i think the plans you pointed out
they would look very sensible here
if i was black here i'd certainly want
to start doing something against my
opponent's king even if it's a very long
plan you know trying to push one of
those pawns and um i i reckon like five
to ten moves it's just gonna come to
light this position because you know
that both sides are going to get near
their opponents king and we're going to
see loads of tactics so i'm excited
about this one and this is the first
time uh lev has really slowed down now
so it's uh it's maybe a sign that he's
you know he he's he's got to work out
what his plan is in the middle game and
um it seems it just seems a little bit
trickier for black to play but um it's
it's certainly not a bad position for
black uh either at the moment
um you've got to think they're playing
the olympiad soon and i i wouldn't have
thought you know they want to show all
their preparation because the olympiad i
mean is is a really really big event and
obviously we're going to have um
mr ashley on oh soon you know and uh
america are top seeds which lev is now
playing for so it's going to be uh very
exciting to see how he's done because
he's won gold medal for armenia before
so many times i mean that's three times
incredible yeah wow armenia is such a
small country i mean in the grand scheme
of things and they've won three times i
think russia didn't win at all in the
meantime
sorry i'm just gonna have to interrupt
you both because um what do you think
about this move which came i'll be
honest with you as a complete shock i
mean i was thinking that black should
perhaps play in a really aggressive
fashion very directly
this one
is very subtle
yeah
trying to work out the idea behind it
black queen just retreating out of the
way of her rook i guess we do talk as
well about uh queen standing at
opposite enemy rooks and white's rook
was on the d-file maybe the black queen
felt a bit uncomfortable there
but that black queen she will need to
move again later to get out yeah i mean
get active
it's getting out the way of that night
jump isn't it when the rook could open
up but it's a really passive square for
the black queen i mean it's just purely
a defensive square there um it can't be
used at all and that gives i mean if i
saw that move i'd be feeling really
confident because i'd be like oh great
my opponent has played a negative move
as in a defensive move
that's good that means i don't even have
to rush this position but i've got him
on the retreat a little bit um and
there's a couple of tempting options i
think wei yi's last move uh was to give
himself space for the bishop and he can
start doing stuff on the queen side with
his that pawn we've mentioned as well um
i guess david you know i mean we saw
yesterday one of the big mistakes that
happened was duda um doing this pawn
move a bit prematurely
before he had got his bishops to the
best square
so i i i would probably just retreat i'd
probably just move that bishop back one
square if i was white here
maybe my queen has a bit more length but
it gets out of the way of any night
jumps and it's a safer square just a
nice you know my opponents played a
nothing move so maybe i play a nothing
move but a better nothing move that's
where i'll be looking at the position
here yeah you improve a loose piece
makes sense the bishop steps back and
then only then will you decide whether
to push these pawns forward or whether
to jump in with the knight
maybe like you said maybe jump out with
the queen at some point
somewhere
yeah it's it's a bit odd i mean if you
showed me this move this queen retreat
the black queen looks pretty nice right
now but if you showed me this move and
you didn't tell me who was playing i
would say oh it's a maybe a slightly
lower rated player who's inexperienced
who
doesn't realize that the queen is pretty
safe for now
because also i mean how is this queen
ever going to get out she's going to
have to use this square again just to uh
kind of enter the action to enter the
game so
yeah a strange one from lavon ironian
talking about the bar as well white has
a plus one advantage but that's because
computers really
love this type of pawn structure
sometimes they overestimate white's
chances when white has this kind of
extra space
uh if you compare it to black's pawn
structure black's pawn structure is nice
and compact like these pawns not
committed and these pawns not committed
but therefore black struggles with space
i think black to dream as well is to
swap off maybe a set of minor pieces
okay he jumps in white now if what if
black can trade off his had a minor
pieces he doesn't get cramped he doesn't
struggle for space but really surprised
about that move because uh
you know your opponent that's what your
opponent's prepared for yeah that's the
only move that makes black's queen
retreat look sensible any other move at
all
and it doesn't make black you know it
doesn't make the last move he's making
that weird move look sensible by putting
the knight there so why why why why do
that i mean it it can't be a bad move
but this is always there and you don't
need to rush such a move maybe it's a
really strong move but it just seems
a little bit
funny to me a little bit i mean how
would you react to this kind of funny
looking move
i'd want to take that night off i mean
because it's so strong if i can so let's
see and then i guess can i just
capture the rook first yep you can trade
instead of um and i say i put another
rook again i'm making that queen move
looks sensible now and when you move
your queen i just take the central
square with a knight or one of the
squares with my knight um for example
and and you know
here you know i've got nice control over
the center and
i think i'm feeling pretty happy here
yeah generally but that knight is worth
the bishop well so he's going for your
plan simon
and uh i completely agree with you yeah
this knight looks beautiful all black
needs is to somehow activate the queen
and all of black's pieces are doing some
pretty good work
okay a computer again not a fan of what
levon's doing but from a human point of
view this looks
really sensible we could see a situation
where white just eliminates this knight
tries to swap off rooks and tries to
bail out
for a draw but that would just be
opposite color bishops
uh here white does have the bishop pair
but they're not great because the center
is mostly blocked
uh we talked about cross crossing
bishops earlier but these bishops
they're just staring at kind of granite
and staring at rocks i was looking at
the square you know
the criss-crossing cross
working trying to get something working
and the action is actually on this
central square where the night sits but
black has that one locked down
the investigations continue yeah we need
to write like a
doctor's uh
yeah yeah on the subject on this pattern
yeah chris anyone wants to fund our
research
phenomena which might take place down
the good night
after the show
do feel free to send us some cash for
the research
research
yes
we would enjoy that yeah we would and
okay the night is in the middle of the
board
i mean
this is the big question to take the
knight or to play with the bishops after
all
two bishops better than one
um maybe if you take the knight ivanka
then i moved the rook down and i i maybe
prefer black's position there because i
don't know possibly i think
yeah it might depend on specifics so for
example if we um do jump in you guys are
saying yeah bishop takes knight is maybe
the most logical move
makes sense black's rook swings across
to create this pin
and the bishop can't move or can white
try and launch an attack against the
black king by for example pushing a pawn
forward after the rook takes the bishop
now jumping out
threatening checkmate on this square
a little bit
yeah a little bit scary isn't it black
and black but now the black queen is
kind of tied down where she is just to
stop the white queen sneaking in
giving checkmate
now white could for example bring the
rook across
but yeah maybe black is just in time to
swap off these rooks
yeah it feels like black is really solid
somehow
there's only one checkmating idea for
white and
it can be prevented there's too much
else going on in the position
way down to four minutes on the clock is
it him playing slow or levon just
playing
very fast it's a bit of both at move 20
in general in rapid chess you don't want
to have used much more than half your
time yeah i mean we've seen plenty of
games go beyond move 50 60 yeah even
sometimes 100 so
to have only four minutes left now is
not ideal that being said i'm always in
the situation myself so i understand
especially when ye he was caught maybe
with a small surprise in the opening
so it took him five or so minutes just
to adapt just to get used to the opening
now is when the big decisions are made
now is when the game is decided you know
on the strategic do you play bishop
takes night do you keep your bishop pair
do you go on the attack all those big
questions so i'm not surprised he's
investing the time now it's just yeah
it's really interesting
but it does have to save some time
because yeah this is one critical moment
but there's more to come
definitely and we're still in the middle
game
and
three minutes now
for way ye ah
and i can just just look at uh levon
he's looking confident
he's got everything under control he's
not in
any danger whatsoever
and those seeds are packing a punch
yeah i i i was going to say also if that
bishop now moves which is attacked
then it just seems like
it validates the the reason that knight
jump was too premature because he could
have the same position by waiting with
that
had he moved that bishop and moved
before you know it could be he could be
saving a whole tempo
because it wasn't really much black was
very cramped and the other thing to bear
in mind
exchanges help the player the side who's
got the more cramped position and you
know four or five moves ago
black had much less space than white
because of white's pawns in the center
and he has moved that bishop again
obviously not a bad move but he could
have this position with white to move so
just exchanges have helped black um and
i mean i i still think white's by the
way absolutely fine
if if not i'd still prefer to be white
but um you know that's what you get when
you play this opening um it could have
been even better maybe yeah just all the
little bits add up don't they uh when
you're playing someone as class as as
lev yeah i mean that's the one tiny uh
criticism i would make about where ye
and some of the other younger players
they do rush slightly in these kind of
slower positions and maybe lev on his
sense that uh hence that black queen
move that we said was mysterious he
sensed that way he was going to do
something kind of uh
something just a bit too hasty and
he was like okay if he's going to jump
in i'm going to get ready for that he's
not going to wait and maneuver like we
were saying he's not going to slowly
improve his pieces because it's the
young way it's kind of
i think we've all been there when we
were young right we don't want to sit
and wait we want to go some of us never
grow up either
i'm still there unfortunately
you know i need to it's a fun way to
play chess i can't wait till your course
comes out then i can learn to grind
that's my grinding move let's not do
anything
like a grandmaster exactly yeah so um
yeah and this this course you've done
with with magnus is going to be
fantastic right i mean uh
magnus hasn't hasn't done many courses
so we're very much looking forward to
getting uh
the gruesome twosome
yeah
chess player and the world's best chess
expert
teaming up for a chess ball course
i'm really looking forward to that yeah
this one this game could still be a
grind a long grind especially while um
the queens and rooks remain on the board
but even if they came off white does
have the bishop pair
some small long-term
uh hopes there i just think that black's
bishop and black's knight are too strong
right now
they should be able to hold the balance
i wouldn't be surprised if the black
queen started coming out i like what way
he's done as well that white dark
squared bishop on the diagonal has
stopped black's rook from swinging to
the d-file
but he's moved that knight away from
that very strong square david and i mean
ivanka would you before i wouldn't have
thought about that move but no i mean
but then again i thought why ye
was being very smart i mean i didn't
quite appreciate the point of his bishop
move out there
until i was like well you know black
should just cement the knight but if you
make any weaknesses on the dark squares
well there's going to be a trade and
then the bishop can cement itself
on d6 square and that is going to be
very unpleasant so uh i
i think levon made a very interesting
choice i don't think i'll be honest i
would make that same move i think i
would perhaps have stepped forward with
the queen to over protect the knight you
know what he wants guys he wants an
octopus on the board that's an octopus
knight on the d3 square i just
remembered
the name for that was coined by young
gustafsson in norwich the kraken kraken
the kraken a knight that sits there on
the d3 square would be called a kraken
because that's like a that's like an
octopus the most scary type right
sailors and pirates was terrified of the
kraken
and in this position black's knight we
talk about the crack in the octopus this
knight could install itself on the d3
square but wei yi has done a great job
with the white queen the white queen
notice how it covers all three pawns
that this knight is attacking so this
black knight now is actually much worse
than it
than it looks it looks like a fantastic
piece supported by black's bishop but
now the white rook can simply swing
across and look at the knight it's
actually trapped behind enemy lines
i'm not gonna drop off i'm really not
sure about erroneous plan i have to say
i i i thought you could have moved the
bishop and pushed his g pawn there then
got the rook in the center like you know
for example just keep that knight there
you know get the rook in the middle um
this you know
why not play something like this i think
that night is just so nice
i mean okay it's come back now but is
the knight really better on this square
uh than than it was in the middle of the
board i'm i'm i'm not convinced at the
moment
um
i mean i don't see how this has helped
uh lev's position really this maneuver
personally okay you're attacking the
queen you're attacking the pawn but
they're very easy to defend
and also now there's an open file which
white has the chance to control because
of that bishop
and uh it wasn't an open file before the
knight was blocking it so i i'm i'm i'm
liking where ye's position now feels
like the calm before the storm though
this little bit small moves and and the
clocks are ticking way ye
i mean it's under two minutes on the
clock yeah looks like this will explode
it definitely will explode and i suspect
that lavon has to do a bit of repair
work i mean there's going to be critical
played along that open line and he has
to act now
yeah just
i just don't see how to get the black
rook in the game that's the problem
black's rook yeah the d8 squared is
controlled by white star square bishop
surely you have to move the the bishop
so you can move the pawn that's the only
thing i was thinking black can do
because you need to get that rook in
don't you
what else can you do here i'm actually
what moves can black play this is always
the problem i can't see what black what
moves black can do here
you know it's it's
i want to move that knight back and put
it in the middle if i was if i was black
here actually i'll just suggest
something something strange from a
beginner
if that's a dark squared bishop the
white one is the problem for lavon how
about blocking with a pawn that's what
we want okay bishop um so we can't block
with this pawn yet okay because this
square is actually protected twice so we
would lose a pawn after pawn takes pawn
a capture and a recapture white would
emerge with an extra pawn at the end
but uh yeah that's the right idea kai
and wow he moves this bishop to this
square this is really odd uh but the
idea is to block out this key bishop
from covering the d8 square he wants to
next move no matter what white does for
example if white swings the rook to the
open file he wants to push this pawn
forward so he's still blocking the
bishop kicking it away it's basically
caillou you nailed it yeah you know
basically you nailed the booth yeah
you did you got the right idea
right away
we have uh fireworks right happening on
the board yes because one attack was met
by a counter-attack hitting white's
bishop and white doesn't want to part
with the bishop pair white's king sits
on this flank as well
so what do you think has this weakened
white's king pushing this pawn forward
now we see a trade of rooks now the rook
comes in
yeah this is big this makes uh this is
really good no he's got black's
certainly improved his position with the
last couple of moves i feel so yeah now
the rooks if they come off
i mean if they come off on black's terms
then black is the only one who occupies
this open file and the queen can't jump
in anyway yet but maybe it could offer
itself up for a trade at some point and
at least you control this uh d-file with
the queen
i guess where yi's idea in the current
position is it to soften up the black
pawns on this flank that's the only
justification i think you can think why
white would push this pawn and open up
the white king yeah i suppose it's worth
thinking you know what what do both
sides want to exchange and i i
originally i was thinking oh maybe lev
wants to get rid of the heavy pieces the
heavy pieces of the rooks and queens but
then i was thinking actually it's
probably wei yi because of some of the
moves that you demonstrate there david
those pawn pushers i'm not convinced but
you know there could be mass exchanges
on the open file
who do we think that benefits i mean
ivanko
if the queens and rooks come off would
you think that helps white or black
um you know i was puzzling about this
issue and i i
just couldn't come up with a solution
actually i mean i was thinking well
white could actually be doing very well
but then again black you could have some
long term potential so i was really
really undecided i would have needed to
look at this position and investigate it
for a lot more than a few minutes i
think this would definitely favor white
i mean you're going to create some
weaknesses if this black pawn was kind
of further back then uh i i think maybe
black would be okay but
i do feel that there'll be some
weaknesses on this side of the board bar
is now jumping up for levon oronion
yeah it's jumping up this last bishop so
the rooks came off the board in this
last bishop retreat
slightly mysterious at the very least
black can kind of go to the corner
attack this pawn and force the white
bishop back where it came from and black
could repeat the position so i think
right now black has that safety net if
he wants he can attack this pawn and
force white's bishop back where it came
from uh go for the draw but i guess he's
also thinking about the ending david
here isn't he because he can
now go for that ending and swap the
queens if he so wishes but i i'm
agreeing with you unless black can get
something very quick from that
the queen exchange should help white
it's not even a case of the two bishops
is it really it's the case that black's
pawns are weaker than white's pawns um
when the queens get exchanged one thing
i would love to do is black just push
upon give the black king some breathing
space while the queen's exists
remain on the board just in case
yeah um yeah i agree with you david i'm
also if i were playing with the black
pieces i would be looking at ways to
mobilize the black knight it kind of
irritates me that it's
just on that square
make an argument for coming in yeah
that's what i want
and then
kind of sliding into the center
yeah the problem is if you move the
knight then white could
offer to swap the queens
again we have to make that decision do
you swap the queens do you trade them
off
and maybe level aronia doesn't want to
trade the queens in the current position
because he's got six minutes against 40
seconds
so you want to keep the queens on the
board if you want to keep winning
chances
yeah okay yeah maybe that would be
annoying moves later maybe you can offer
you know i didn't realize why he's under
a minute i mean i sort of he's got 40
seconds so what do you think right now
looking at the clock looking at the
board will we have a winner in this game
too
if i don't know it's in the balance if
anyone i would say aronian just because
of the momentum of the game it's all
been going black's way ever since huayi
kind of rushed and got impatient and
kind of made that knight c5 move earlier
that simon was discussing
uh so it feels like aronian's asserted
his authority slightly on this game he's
been outplaying wei yi in his kind of
small little details but still a long
long way to go white's position is still
super solid defending all the pawns i've
just
i've just seen what the computer is
i saw
the computer's on drugs
[Laughter]
it recommends i just just checking
because to me i like david's move give
the king an escape square just just like
play some move but he wants to go b5 of
course
no okay
anyone i bet that ronin doesn't play
that move in 100 years or even in this
game anyone want to bet that he plays b5
you'll never ever play that never
so that's pushing the pawn in front the
black king two squares i mean through
that i i mean he
he will never play it he's not even
looking at that no way oh he can't be
supportive this is apparently what the
computer says is
the best move right it looks ridiculous
to me i mean if firstly you allow on
pass on and we discussed
it's very unnatural as a human to even
allow that
he doesn't play it for a second i
thought my mom might appear on the board
that was never going to happen but i
guess the idea is that you bypass
white's porn if he doesn't take if he
takes okay great
black structure still pretty solid but
if he doesn't take then black's knight
is on a nice outpost it can no longer
ever be challenged by a pawn
but uh instead the knight jumped in and
i really don't like this decision from
levon aronian if he wants to win this
game now he plays the idea but uh now
but the queens are off that is the big
difference and okay now he pushes his
pawn he's got an idea of creeping in
with his king
but
same idea with the queen's on would have
been stronger and with wei under 40
seconds he's so happy the queens have
come off
with the queens on
all three results possible still all
three results possible but white has a
margin for error
okay queen's off okay a trader pawns
and uh
do you think that where you will perhaps
instinctively try to soften up the
no he doesn't he retreats the bishop
yeah and this is a nice overprotecting
move i like it i mean maybe not the most
direct but it's i think it's very good
what do you think guys if the black
knight ever
jumps in or maybe maybe not to the
square but for example in a square like
this will we ever see a trade
going into opposite color bishops is
where you playing for the draw
i'd be surprised i mean just from the
evidence of where he's previous games
even when he's short time he
he doesn't really like that draw does he
he'll play on and on but
um
it may be a wise decision
yeah i mean knight comes to the center
that's even maybe a little bit tricky to
ending yeah slightly tricky yeah so okay
instead the black knight jumps into the
d3 square we saw this uh reward level
neronian yesterday against duda and he's
maybe hinting at taking it off maybe
you're right maybe maybe he will just
because that'll be just a draw
immediately if he takes the if he gets
the opposite kind of bishops in an
ending as i'm sure most you aware
opposite kind of bishops uh is often a
draw
we're talking about bobby fischer and
spansky uh who said might you know i
think when he divorced his wife he was
like
we were just like opposite kind of
bishops moving on different college
squares
you know
passing each other you know not
connecting
um so yeah i met many marriages
similarly to that
yeah
absolutely but um okay the night has
been driven backwards it's gone to the
f4 square and uh this does allow the
white king to take a step a step forward
and uh
he's chasing that knight hmm
this is the way he playing ambitious is
he uh trying to find a win in this game
even with 42 seconds on this i have a
feeling that he's just trying to gain
time on his clock he's only got 42
seconds and before you initiate active
operations it's always good to build
some extra time
i guess he can draw here right he can go
bishop takes knight
and uh we get mass exchanges he'll
probably win a pawn
so this is a drawing move definitely um
as in you're going to win a kingside
pawn as white here i think yeah
one of your pawns drops on the queen
side at least black can win a pawn right
now the white a2 pawn is hanging
there we go so yeah as you mentioned
simon white will win a pawn on the
opposite flank most likely
and it should be a draw now
is it so easy actually if you push this
f pawn
because after all the h6 pawn is gonna
drop and then you have a nice past pawn
to advance that pawn's easy to deal with
for black unfortunately okay bishop will
just slide down to the b1 square guard
diagonal
but uh yeah at least
we'll see this game continue for a while
it's not the most dead of opposite color
bishop and games
usually they're completely balanced
don't even have to discuss it but here
that we will see some pawn imbalances um
some pawn races potentially
okay
very tense this final so far this is
game two in the first match the first
one ended with a droll of one had the
white pieces and uh that one some
fighting but it was a drawing in this
one as well
we're seeing some fighting but it feels
tense it feels like they're not
daring to put all out there because it's
just
so critical to lose a game it kind of
feels like two big cats kind of like
circling each other you know just maybe
prodding here trying to see
a weakness yeah and uh well levon pushes
his c pawn forward and uh now we're
gonna see
the h pawn become past
yeah black's king meanwhile ready to
enter the position
white's king doing the same you've got
to use those kings in the end game
and uh yeah looks like a decent plan for
black
centralizing the black king
white's king doing the same of course
black does have a two versus one on the
other side so white can't
fully ignore that and push his h pawn
forward
the central pawn for white under fire
right now
yeah unfortunately i think neither side
has too many chances here
okay white's going for it valuation pass
slightly up for white
okay just recorrecting itself
yeah i mean
some some still some play left i i guess
i mean like ivanka mentioned that
passport white at the moment does have a
passport and black doesn't have a
passport so
i'd be shaking hands here though
but he i think he has an idea and as a
bit long and of course black is also
playing but you know
somehow the miracle would be is if the
black if the dark square bishop could
stop black's uh past pawns and then
for example something like this yeah
some yeah that would be good that would
be very helpful and then uh somehow or
other
the white king managed to
so you need to kind of all the stars to
align so black does nothing the white
king steps in
finally the white king steps in wins
this pawn or helps this pawn run forward
yeah and supports it going to the h7
square you basically need aronian to
play like five terrible moves
to get a slight chance
and
i don't see that happening and and
probably the same goes your way around
right i mean aronian can get a past porn
but he's going to need wei yi to play
some terrible moves in order in order to
make that any of any use whatsoever so
yeah trying a similar plan maybe he's
provoked this pawn to much forward now
he's going back so he's hoping that
levon plays this move that we
highlighted uh just allowing the white
bishop kind of to come around and sit on
a nice square blockading the black pawns
yeah it's uh
it's interesting it definitely feels
like wei yi now that or the risk is out
of the position that he's going to try
and probe and
hope for some uh kind of inaccuracies
from levon
all white needs actually is to put the
bishop on this square and then he can
start going in with his king yeah mm-hmm
okay better play better yeah i mean
maybe we've written off too soon maybe
aronian is the one defending
you'd be playing this on when you david
yeah rule 101 of grinding never agree a
draw
fight till king versus king if you need
to have you have your wars be like that
i mean because i know
personally like when i was a lot younger
i was kind of prone to taking draws then
i realized like you know taking drawers
is just bad for your chest you don't
learn anything
and you should always basically avoid
taking a draw but um when i was younger
i was very happy to take a draw and you
know just uh get it over with in
occasions if i was a bit scared bit
nervous but have you been have you been
any always a fighter always avoiding
draws yeah at least until
the last few years i mean recently i've
in the last few years i took a few more
draws or at least guided games towards
draws just because i was feeling tired
or something in life was affecting me
and i just wanted to save my energy
maybe but when i was younger i didn't
care about saving energy i just wanted
to fight i wanted to win and i wanted to
learn it's a great strategy and your
vancouver is obviously going to ask you
the same question i mean
have you always avoided draws or um no
no i was like you simon i took draws
when i was feeling slightly nervous or
playing someone with a higher rating and
uh
wow well well
liquid porn advanced forward
and
slightly strange decision it is a bit
strange and now the age pawn takes two
squares forward
yeah so black's pawns are easily
blockaded at least
uh aronian just wants to do all the work
with his king he's kind of initiating a
race in a way so black's king wants to
come down towards that white b pawn
takes a long long time
and uh meanwhile white's h pawn
yeah very strong it's a little bit yeah
i mean if i was black i'd start to be
like oh hang on a minute this is not as
easy as i thought and uh i'd be starting
to get a bit worried basically here so
yeah just the fact that white's plan is
so straightforward yep
oh certainly
the h pawn now maybe i mean this looked
like a good way to
i mean the black king is coming
very close to the uh white's remaining
pawn on that side of the board so so i
think it's i think it's still absolutely
fine oh 10 seconds for away though it
should be big threat though white's h
pawn it's two squares away max king
needs to move away so that his bishop
guards the diagonal
look at lavon
he's panicking big decision where does
he put the king he has a choice of four
squares right now one of them clearly
loses now you can't put the black king
on c2 because you continue blocking your
bishop you need to jump out the way do
you think he might be uh actually
gambling on getting his own queen
you're pushing the pawn
maybe oh he's super risky
i like piguet i like the way you said
jump out the way
it's got a very chess name because we
say way
ye
[Laughter]
all right well look at lavon he is not
looking comfortable the bar is really
liking this for wei yi game two can the
chinese player get a win here oh god
it's really gone up actually i was gonna
say the bar has shot up all the way over
to the white side and we were right this
end game off as a trivial draw yeah i
mean the black the white king can't
can't it come in does it come in now
well no not quite zigzag it's way in and
on the dark squares that white king we
highlighted this plan this is white's
main winning plan and black has done
nothing to stop it
yeah i do have a feeling that levon's
easiest draw all that time ago was to
just not bring his king into the center
black's king should have gone the whole
way across the board to the h file just
earlier just even if you lose your queen
side lose one of the pawns it was a dead
draw there locate the light squares
now the black king is just waiting and
look at he's about to repeat the
position once just he loves this guy he
did that yesterday as well
second time we've seen this position
and
now the white king can move forward yeah
go in i mean but is is this winning
this is like such a complicated uh
position
to calculate a win
he does have time well 28 seconds not
that much so this he's doing the right
thing where he's just
building up time on the clock and when
he's got enough
he will make that commitment
yeah but it feels like now you have to
stop the black king continuing going
towards the white pawns
the white king only has one square to
enter the black position so just use
that square now level shaking his head
yeah i mean this oh
he's just trying not to commit where he
strange don't know what he's doing he
could have gone for it with still zero
risk involved
okay go back with the white king now
it's the only way
another thing i'll notice he doesn't
like committing where he does he you
know he always tries to
do every single thing else before he
makes a decision
you know when it comes to these type of
things and
he loves going around in circles really
that's the way of the grinder the way of
the grinder i like it
he's doing a good job of grinding yeah
i'm getting in there getting into the
grind exactly issues maybe yeah
definitely yeah that's not necessarily a
bad thing as well often just by going
around in circles like this where he
might provoke a mistake from levon levon
might get impatient be like come on
let's uh let's start this race this pawn
race
let's uh
do something at least okay the black
king we're going back
uh just stopping any potential
incursions from the white king
computer hates it of course but
white's king now is likely to step up
one square
it feels like he's
sorry well we have a winner in this game
what do you think now i have a feeling
if the position is objectively winning
we're not 100 sure a lot of calculation
is needed once white's king starts
going into the position he'll drop some
pawns and a race will start but if the
position is objectively winning i think
wei yi will win
because he will go for it eventually
he won't just repeat the position and go
for a draw he has to go in with the
white king
yeah
now go in yeah you have to play
at some point don't you yeah i was a bit
surprised by uh love waiting with his
king i thought he would wait with his
bishop okay no
still delaying he's still not committing
the king move it forward
now i'm wondering
due to the black king location did he
miss this small window of opportunity
earlier
or i mean why is he not going in with a
white king now
i just don't understand i mean this is
going to be a draw scene uh this remind
this brings me brings back flashbacks of
anisha's game you know when i heard the
50 move rule right and uh it went all
the way to 50 moves i mean he he had to
push that pawn didn't he and that's the
extremes of
commitment issues where anish didn't
want to commit he didn't want to gamble
he was happy to kind of leave the
tournament
rather than gamble this must be three
times now i mean okay the king oh
finally
steps up the board
and uh okay
levon follow suit
i was thinking you'd yeah okay i mean
this position kind of is key right yeah
but it it will be a race whatever
happens and white could have had that
exact position with his self to move
about 15 20 moves ago
so what is the key now
can you advance with the white king
forward
you do give up the white g pawn but of
course he's not going to come
he's going to wait around yeah
and join himself too much here
i guess the idea is that the white king
at some point has to zig zag two squares
in
and then push
the h pawn right this is the way to do
it the only way to win and
black will then have to give his bishop
up for that pawn
and can black
then draw that position yeah let's
maybe jump in because wei yi he's got to
go for this if he wants to win his only
winning plan is to jump in as simon
mentions the black king will take a pawn
he jumps in again
i'm not really sure where the black king
goes uh but then you win black's bishop
and the question is
for example after i guess this pawn
pushes what else for black the question
is here are you winning as white can you
stop these two pawns
and can you keep your own pawn alive
where ye thinks this this is a draw and
maybe it is because white's king is so
poorly placed white's king is just i'd
be a little bit scared playing that
position as white as well i mean that's
why he's not going for it he's scared of
course yeah you could lose that ending
yeah in in some extreme cases because
those those pawns are really quick so i
i can understand why he he hasn't gone
for this and
that would indicate it's probably a draw
right yeah i mean i was just wondering
whether he could try to be smart and put
his bishop on a better square
so uh
yeah i mean the problem is in the
current position where does white put
his bishop he's kind of used he's used
this square he's used this square he's
used this square and this square
yeah my vibe was to put it on the d6
square
okay on this square
um interesting so in the current
position he could go there what's the
difference if black awaits
yeah and uh the whole point is that the
the pawn doesn't come with uh time when
it doesn't hit you later so for example
you could go for it now i think it would
end up in the exact same position
unfortunately but
um yeah it's all about whether white at
some point can go in with the king
zigzag and win the black bishop by
pushing this pawn
just doesn't look possible unfortunately
yeah it looks a little bit dangerous and
uh four seconds and uh yeah i don't
think he's going to go for it at all
yeah it's just too much risk involved at
the moment and you can't take the risk
with 10 seconds on your clock he's
probably spent the last 20 moves
calculating that line as well so yeah i
think and it looks like they're going to
shake hands have they shaking hands now
yeah
and uh shaking his head as well lavon
aronian with the black
pieces in this game too it ends
with a draw with what's happening oh
that's the analysis board oh sorry i'm
still playing through